bonjour cet homme s'appelle à jean
dujardin a dit john forme de gordes son
âge vingt cinq ans sa mission conquérir
les filles on the beach cet homme
s'appelle bruno salomon loi dit bruno
senna ou moins 27 ans et sa mission
s'est séparé que moi en fait tous moi ne
vous inquiétez pas salut ça va
parfois on sent seul temps vous allez où
là
à moi aussi j'aime les pattes mais tu
veux pas m'aider à me balader un peu
parce que
owen en battant qui du copain je peux
m'allonger et la surface à l'aide
je fais mon favori
sony quoi la mamelle
c'est vraiment la paix
et tous sont les connaît si bien manger
réponse équipe tu veux je te vois tu as
peu de crème mais un petit peu ici là
pas trop envie de parler là
sa copine non plus n'a pas besoin de
parler
je veux moi je n'aurais pas parié gros
lourd ccsa bon
je peins vas-y shatwan en tous temps
vous avez l'air cool comme ça et
pourtant merde alors je comprends pas
la bâche que je me prends c'est la
première fois en trois courses assez
kodak
je suis complètement désolé j'y allais à
nyala c'est vrai ça tu aimes pas ça à la
fin
dans les cours paulette on s'embrasse
rabiu joue en battant 6-1 80,1 moi aussi
merci voilà
à très bientôt bon ben c'est vrai que la
journée a pas été très brillante
bon c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas trop
emballé
ou bonjour aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
un continent aussi génial mois jean qui
est mon petit frère non si génial mois a
du mal à draguer mais juste avec les
filles et l albatros il se sent
maladroit facto inhabiles où il est
juste avec effet aujourd'hui c'est un
grand jour pour lui ah bon et moi car à
l'intérieur de ce camping
j'ai caché la femme de sa vie me
séparerai non c'est pas vrai quand même
d'accord je ne quittez pas
bonjour
bonjour jean nommant jean voilà j'ai
très envie de draguer mais non gens il
ne faut pas le dire il faut le suggérer
je peux te suggérer que j'ai très envie
de draguer genre ce que tu fais c'est
pas mauvais c'est très mauvais alors
cherchant toit soit plus poétique
d'accord des yeux sont comme une vaste
vallée où vogue sans vanité de granero
van eeuwen ou mais ça va pas plaire
maman alors fait le strict minimum
mais soit plus comique ne soit plus
tonique tollé tout tourne autour d'orio
territoriaux toyota tout aux
constatations
la danse c'est pas ton truc surprend la
taxe et les bons de garde et écoute
oh toi ma muse un jour tu seras mienne
rejoins moi dans ma tente c'était une
canadienne renault à mon avis il
faudrait qu'ils soient moins cavalier
bon ben ça c'est pas très bien passé
c'est vrai quoi on n'a pas trompé
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la coupe
non nous sommes à la compagnie a'corps
pas non à la mer ouais mais quand même
un peu la compagnie d'accord mais où
sont les femmes
il ya un problème
justement comment draguer une femme la
mère avec un décor de campagne elle tout
en sachant qu'ici les femmes sont plutôt
des choses
démonstration il ne quitte pas cette
fille me plaît elle est douce belle et
sensuelle et doit très bien faire les
quenelles bonjour bonjour denise jean la
main denise tu me plaît je te veux il
n'a pas vu que c'était moi tu es très
jolie pour la région l'espèce humaine si
facile
cette femme manger bien vu que je peux
et bruno il n'a pas vu que c'était moi
tu es très jolie pour la région c'est
pas gagné il va falloir la séduire ici
pour épater les femmes il faut une super
bagnols et savoir assurer sur le
mobilier il faut également l'emmener
dans des promenades bucoliques l'emmener
voir ses copines l'emmener aux
expositions lui offrir une cuisine qui
lui ressemble et s'intéresser à sa vie
quotidienne
et qu'est ce qu'il fait en ce moment
denise lâche-t-elle parle se parfumer
tue mais notre collègue
[Musique]
écumez rien
là
à
[Musique]
du bez les femmes adorent senti qu'on a
du blé ta peau cuivrée et aidant à créer
tes cheveux de feu me font frémir mais
non c'est pas crédible
les cheveux de feu j'ai les cheveux
bruns ah merde où la rue et je peux
charbon un bon charbon c'est bien faire
bon c'est bien sûr on sait bien céder
charbon bon bah ça s'est plutôt bien
passé
c'est vrai que il a réussi à montaner et
en plus bonjour bonjour salut bonjour
aujourd'hui nous sommes à dove et albert
[Applaudissements]
regard ouais mais pour draguer ici il
faut doubler
bonjour à beauval
il ya une qualité de vie et une
luminosité extraordinaire
tu crois tu vas le faire là méritait pas
ici les hommes sont toutes des pêcheurs
à deauville c'est impossible de ben ali
jana chabadabada chabadabada chabadabada
chabadabada
la dame chabadabada madame irina
tu téléphones maintenant tu baises la
semaine dernière je suis parti une
semaine au sénégal
ouais moi c'est pareil mais mieux
bonjour cellules es tu sais que je
connais hyper bien le batteur des
forbans
bonjour
on entend même
[Musique]
dis donc tu connais la série l'instit
avec gérard klein un moment on voit un
mec qui passe à hervé encore pas à la
base les femmes de salé non négligeable
le mans et réclamant son côté dit il ya
de très très bientôt
là tu peux l'écrire je ne plierai qu'il
fera un bon ben ça c'est pas très bien
passé c'est vrai que globalement nous
n'avons pas réussi au bal 1 1 enfin bon
on s'est bien marré bonjour salue
aujourd'hui nous avons rendez vous avec
greta et père guide dans un camping
naturiste
autant vous dire qu'on a les crocs mais
d'abord il faut passer chez mamie
monopole ont tant aimé quand même un
petit peu on avait promis on va ne pas
longtemps on avait promis
bon ne quittez pas pendant ton premier
voilà omar hammami rival à l'enap là je
vous ai fait une bêta ça va pas changer
du tout ab ça c'était pas tout on se
révolte et calme la télé oui et alors
c'est les vacances
un nom c'est toujours pareil oui on
devait partir pour aller voir là la
région lui la région il est bien sûr de
belles régions à voir et c'est dommage
pour une fois tu veux bien rester un peu
plus longtemps
je sais pas pourquoi mais moi j'ai déjà
mangé bon bin hammam il ya un moment où
il faut partir sur un allez on y va
allez mon retour
il atteint méconnaît surprise jouer à
chat wi fi n de kaya déplumé lui tacle
le mono oui elles sont partis là c'est
mort l'axé morts je prends ma carte sauf
qu'un sont pas inscrits donc voilà ça va
tenir ça va tu vois la cour tu vois
cours les enfants je vous ai retrouvé
votre ballon tenez j'ai pas envie de
rester ici vous fait des tares joue au
ballon faire la sieste l'afutt y avait
deux bronzes est lui attendu compris les
coûts de gens fin mai mme nezha élevé
dans les traditions et moi aussi je me
disais allô oui allô oui c'est de ces
pour s'être message pour tous jeunes
filles emplacement 4 c'est une tombe peu
jaune leur dire qu'on arrivera à 18
heures
ouais pourquoi d'auteur mais j'en ai
marre
bon bah c'est vrai que ça s'est pas très
bien passé ça mais c'est vrai on n'a pas
du tout emballé on s'est plutôt familier
non non tu m'a carrément fait chier mais
par contre on l'a dérangé un salut
aujourd'hui nous sommes la nuit ou non
mais sinon ça sinon la regarde
ah ouais et qu'est-ce qu'on fait la nuit
en boîte
allez c'est parti les fêtes ont sonné la
super soirée mais cazilhac 1 ce soir on
se dessine sur des pousses de noces
c'est parti ne quittez pas bonjour je
prends plein la boîte était combien jeu
tout seul fait accompagner
c'est un jour bonjour jetant à terre la
boîte à cons je suis neuf
en effet voilà une période assez bon
[Musique]
genève est à peine arrivé déjà à son
aise répond alain derrière ça sent pas
avec toi vie des gens
les saisonniers ici là à savoir des
zozos les garçons car sauf jours fériés
de la bataille à quoi le chenail de la
bonne bataille
à quoi la chenille la bande à basile
série et sochaux
salut tant qu'île je t'apprends wah wah
lavabos robinets
je te penses quoi toi ta burqa c'est
vous c'est ton caddie ville est alors la
fille du vestiaire jubilait après la
divine et le suivi des tickets c'est un
fils bcg qui le vieux bus tiens c'est ma
soeur mon attention c'est moins cher
soit danseur bon danseur
alors tu as et moi ça se passe pas comme
ça ici sur une fille tu me donnant
l'autorisation verbale inventif demande
ou alors est ce que seront livrés chose
que je veux moi l'expression mais on se
ressemble et je te lance un défi sur la
pelouse hier bon c'est vrai que ça ne
s'est pas très bien passé c'est vrai que
moi j'ai pas franchement emballé on
vient de lancer aujourd'hui mon badge
aujourd'hui le bonjour vous pouvez me
prendre du plaisir
sympa elle est grave comme monde
en tout cas c'est très gentil merci
justin prix jean luc non genre là les
verrous comme ça j'allais dans une
auberge de jeunesse vient chez moi c'est
opère chaque 11 aces je crois qu'on va
bien s'amuser tous les teints tintin
[Musique]
tu es mon autre circulent ici à ta guise
mais ne tarde en tueur jamais dans la
chambre bleue c'est d'en faire ici il ne
croit pas si bien dire
tintintin vas-y profite de la vie am
histoire suis ici chez moi c'est très
gentil mais d'où vient cet homme il n'a
pas vu que c'était moi à bien y regarder
comme c'est étrange je m'amuse et
pourtant cet homme me fait peur vas-y
régal toi mais ne va jamais dans la
chambre bleue
tintintin
mais pourquoi tant de mystère autour de
cette chambre bleue mais qui parles-tu à
un copain réalisateur fabien lucifer
lucifer fabien saluant chanter tu fais
comme chez toi n'est pas dans la chambre
bleue
tintintin
il est gros mais voici ta punition non
répond plus aux 1 prend pour le soir
lara bruneau web et des palais dhabi -
ouais c'est vrai que ça s'est plutôt
bien passé comme ça on a super bien
emballé enfin il aime c'est qu'on a rêvé
or qu'est-ce qu'on fait bon bah il
attendait toujours fait l'écho
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la recherche
de doses amassant c'est quoi mady des
femmes alors oui mais sauvage ramadier
femme sauvage ou mais amazon ça peut
frapper l accord ne comprennent pas ou
pas du mal notre mission les localiser
dans l'écosystème c'est quoi la nature
vanille la nature alors oui mais qu'aux
systèmes 100g train quand même tu as
compris et j'ai perdu pas mal
effectivement attendre 1971 un pilatus
pire acteur black hat à airlines s'est
abîmé dans l'un des bars des vendéens à
son bord deux points
la famille princière de la principauté
salinas de la course donc survécu à la
catastrophe que les deux filles cadettes
de sexe féminin gachnang quittez pas
tintin
ils marchèrent durant des jours et des
lunes il n'avait qu'un seul objectif on
m'a dit alors que l'avion s'était crashé
en 71 donc elle devrait avoir 26 ans
regarde perez de l'appareil ça se trouve
à sont à l'intérieur je m'en venais ça à
chaud pour ce bon chemin il ne croise
air que des cageots il nous avait fait
faux
il avait soif et faim mais ils avaient
leurs jets fin à ce soleil me rend fou
je n'ai plus la force bruno rejoint le
côté obscur a rejoint le côté obscur
rabat vient là il ya moins de soleil du
mal à lemieux l'a beaucoup mieux soudain
ils aperçurent un bruit n'ont pas vu que
c'était ces femmes on a bien vu que
c'était nouveau
une marche air durant des jours et des
lunes c'est un double ça se trouve
l'avion se serait crashé en 1926 à leurs
prêts donc 71 ans au bon ben ça c'est
pas trop bien passé
c'est vrai qu'on s'est carrément trompé
d'année enfin on s'est bien marré on
voit ça lui au gua salue aujourd'hui on
rentre à paris non c'est non c'est non
ces bons restent à la mer ouais mais
quand même un peu d'accord mais qu'est
ce qu'on va faire un pari gagné des sous
mais pourquoi faire partir en vacances
on y est déjà
ah ouais n'hésitez pas
dans la pas marre de le filmer ta caméra
la part de nous poursuivre partout l'a
déjà les vacances ça suffit maintenant
cette vidéo tu as dit on rentre on tadic
rentrée bon tu nous lâche encore la
toile bon tu as dit nous lâcher là c'est
bon on a vu qu'on était plus drôles les
plus drôles à terraria possible on était
trop fatigué e 1
oui non ouais voilà en route à gagner
plus drôle
alors voilà et genre quoi j'en vois tu
as une tâche là un rôle normal on arrête
de nous bouffer un petit ballon jetons
bêtisier bonjour aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans un temps non bonjour un jour
[Rires]
bonjour le vent soufflait les femmes
adorent le sport est affiché salut tu
sais que je connais hyper bien le
batteur des forbans tu vois la série n 1
0 qui s'ébat je m'appelle jean bruneau
nommé bonjour jean un nom non merde
bon ben sahar est qu on s'est un peu
gros frais vous a pas tout montrer mais
par contre il pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu